On Saturday, the 16th, I began to have watery bubbly 10 diarrhea.
Sorry, it extreme fatigue, nausea, lack of appetite, it extreme gloat.
The only thing I could choke down is mashed potatoes.
So this question that you asked, this person asked last week,
but now they says they've been to the doctor twice,
they've got some testing done.
The culture showed the morgue de la, so the morgue de la,
morgue de la is a gram negative bacteria, so which my doctor said has been
lying dormant in my system from the pink slide I had for a chemo.
Oh, he of course was going to prescribe antibiotics, but thought it worth a try
to heal it naturally first since I've been on so many interventions.
I'm also very low in potassium from the concept diarrhea.
I've been taking some provedic probiotic enzymes, a binder,
a charcoal against sense Monday night.
I felt terrible on Monday, much better yesterday and low again today.
Do you have any suggestions on how to tweak things?
I'm doing as well as other things that might help.
And what should I have the right for diarrhea?
No, I would run bacteria programs.
So I would run infection programs, bacteria programs, and pretty sure there's not
a program for morgue de la.
I don't think there is, but that's what those are things I would run.
It's a bacteria though, so you have to kill it.
The only thing you mention that you would, that you're taking that would probably help
would be charcoal.
So charcoal can be effective against bacteria.
So what you might want to bump the dose that you'll find in a little bit,
so you also think what are you going to do to help kill bacteria?
Well, burberry is a good thing to help kill bacteria.
Garlic is a good thing to help kill bacteria.
So those are the things that could be bacteria killers in the gut.
That's what I would consider is burberry,
and garlic, charcoal.
That's what I would do.
And run, I would run the diarrhea program.
I would run bacteria, I would run infection.
That's what I would run it in the rice.